Mary Stewart is condemned to death by
order of our sovereign Elizabeth Queen
of England how did it come to this there
is news King Francis is dead
your cousin Mary has returned to rule in
Scotland
she is formidable madam so she comes
ready for war not so I need command
armies but tell my cousin that we pray
for peace
I hope we might meet in person
and resolve our destinies you must
confront the truth madam
she has acclaimed your throne
you would have me to post a system on it
is either Civil War there what civil war
here we have a scourge upon our land a
woman with a crappy what says her
brother because allegiance is fully with
us there's no our potato war and let us
start an appetite oh cool men are all I
have done it's tried to unify this land
that they are trying to use her my crime
a murderer a traitor and to Queen but I
will be the woman she is not we bring
into this world
and here to Scotland and to England
they're like no we need if you speak if
it 21 I shall tonight be my boys
godmother he make sister Mary is our
first we ask that we never bow to her as
we bow before you you cannot raise an
army many times you have said I cannot
do what I have done
do not play into their hands your heart
has more within it than the men who came
for you they would do well to watch or
work I will not be scolded by my
inferior
[Music]
if you motivate you murder your sister
and you murder your queen
how did it come to this
you
you